en pleine période estivale les
automobilistes ne semblent pas très bien
informé sur la nouvelle prime à la
conversion
franchement je sais rien
pour l'instant je désire pas changer de
véhicule donc je pas très concernés
on a juste un petit peu informés c'est
vraiment
pour des des conditions assez strictes
quoi dans ce concessions ils viennent de
recevoir les nouvelles dispositions
voiture thermique super plume pour les
un critère un et deux hybrides
rechargeables une usine à gaz diraient
certains
aujourd'hui si la mise en place et
complexe puisqu'il ya pas mal de
critères qu'il faut bien respecter donc
les émissions de co2
les revenus sont à prendre en charge par
part fiscale donc donc vraiment un focus
aussi sur ce point là une chose est sûre
cette nouvelle prime signe la fin du
diesel la 508 ne l'est pas ça c'est un
gros moteur diesel donc de facto c'est
exclu la 208 like qui est à 105 grammes
de co2 forcément est en dessous des 116
donc en bénéficier avec le seuil de 116
grammes on exclut de facto quasiment
toute la gamme diesel
donc il ya plus que les véhicules
essence et encore des véhicules essence
récent qui peuvent bénéficier de la
prime à la conversion
c'est à dire que jusqu'à jusqu'au mois
de jusqu'à fin juillet
ça nous arrivait de vendre avec des
primes à la conversion des véhicules qui
avaient 7 8 ans six sept huit mille
euros aujourd'hui ces véhicules là ne
pourront plus bénéficier de la prime à
la conversion
la réforme impose également un prix
maximum de soixante mille euros par
véhicule et favorisant priorité
l'électrique
les plus anciens eux sont déjà convertis
95 gens aimeraient que leur style